Jace's [ __ ] christ [ __ ] uncut in the
buddies and Gemma's [ __ ] idea or
[ __ ] at Hales gum bros my name is
Pete
welcome to Ben and Ed this game looks
hilarious I'm trying something new here
today we're gonna call it uncut no
matter what in the butt the in the butt
part is completely unnecessary but oh
god that's so creepy I didn't see that
little thing there basically no matter
what happens in this gameplay no matter
if so if I get swatted okay now this is
[ __ ] already no matter what happens I
will not cut the gameplay hopefully it
will make it a smoother more relaxed
experience I do a lot of edits in my
videos so I thought to change it up a
little bit then we will have uncut once
in the but I play this game a little bit
it's really funny but I thought let's
let's create a new game and let said
let's do this I'm sure you've cheated on
me already and watch someone else play
this but either way I'm gonna forgive
you
cuz I'm okay whatever this has been he
lives in a crappy world one day been
founded the first undead I like that he
wears a headband with always bald don't
worry no one knows your ball dead they
became friends
oh he's blushing alright see already the
story is completely unrealistic cuz
there's no way if he was poor that he
can afford a steak like that huh Hans
show master heard of them
I find it a little bit racist and
offensive that they made the main
villain German and his beard is like a
[ __ ]
what are those called the place you walk
over the street on ever going steadily
got it
alright I'm Swedish it's okay he took
them apart to use them
it looks like Hans is into some kind of
weird bondage [ __ ] that's good and for
the greatest game show ever created run
dead Wow backstage what the [ __ ] am I
looking at
no honestly what am I looking at oh okay
that I was looking at my own armpit on
the inside that's good
here we go this is me WASD to move
thanks for that game give us a kiss
Thank You Hans Snowdown we'd shift laugh
at the weak that sounds like a good show
jump yay so in case you don't know
already this game is about running
tracks and surviving the real beauty of
the game is yet to be revealed take head
throw head got it nailed yeah I can
reattach to my body
[ __ ] hell Oh God I would clearly have
edit I [ __ ] up that's a very sexy button
makes very sexy noises I think I just
cleaned my pants can I get inside my ass
I can best game ever ten out of ten
e to interact
got it here we go checkpoint doing great
so far I'm proud of myself
a bronze [ __ ] you press ENTER to respawn
at checkpoint anywhere anytime yeah I
got a gold alright alright alright let's
begin this feels like a full life
tourism - yay we did it press pretty
good time - 1 out of 4 dog meats [ __ ]
that let's move on to level 2 I'm pretty
sure and we can do this are you still
here Am I are you bored because there's
no cuts damn it I know it I find safety
first
thanks mom
hey what's up I'm run it I'm gonna
[ __ ] run like a bug a little bit all
right here we go going for the goat
safety first
okay all right I'm gonna get cut just -
no way I don't want to do it
Oh God alright get all the candy I don't
wait there dog food alright we're still
on gold technically there's no timer but
I know that if I do it fast [ __ ] me in
the ass
if I do it faster it will be better this
music is [ __ ] stressing me out Jesus
Christ there's this camera guys as well
I know I can like take my head and knock
them out but we're not gonna we're not
gonna do that
we got a bronze [ __ ] that come on a
bronze might as well give up on life I
guess technically I will learn to have
if I'm a zombie okay we got hammers now
not a problem clearly not a problem for
me duck dodge roll and [ __ ] that's up ah
get up
we're fine I'm fine see the game starts
up very easy it will get harder she said
goddamn it we're fine
never again run dick run dick
come on baby so far we haven't been cut
that's generally a good thing oh these
are getting lower as we go
no problem oh I thought zombies were
supposed to run slow though like I feel
like I'm missing something
still pretty Zee still haven't get cut
in the butt damn it we can still do it
never might uh tree attach we're fine
I'm fine I'm fine doing it for my
breasts
come on baby whoo okay this is
ridiculous oh god this one is short
don't cut off my balls I don't think you
can actually no damn it
all right [ __ ] I don't need that anyway
I'm fine run net isn't he's a real
trooper what the [ __ ] did I just loose
what the [ __ ] did I lose my dick I don't
mean for perverse but that really scene
looked like it didn't take they I would
have done a replay there but I can't
[ __ ] it there we go
I'm fine just gotta make the next [ __ ]
point oh so you really need the speed if
you slow down you're kind of [ __ ] but
I really didn't think I would fail this
early in the game I'm so sorry I feel
like I failed your breasts don't worry
about it
I got this they say normally your
brothers would think I'm really good at
games no one no okay well at least [ __ ]
get up you can still do it I can see in
a checkpoint ah yeah reattach baby [ __ ]
your chickens I don't know why I kill
you I just I just like it I don't think
that was [ __ ] man I don't anything bad
[ __ ]
I think I saw a porno like this one I
mean I'm edit that okay I think I saw
whatever is [ __ ] okay now I'm distracted
Jesus Christ sit hot in here man it's
hard to do uncut jesus [ __ ] christ
okay take it easy there we go right nice
and smooth baby nice and smooth like I
imagined Edd's but not to be it's
probably wrinkly and awkward like my own
okay yeah dodging and that'll do the
trick
okay we have yet to throw the head I
don't know what that when we'll do that
oh Jesus
the [ __ ] did we reattach another thing
that will help where are we are they're
like Easter eggs I bet there's Easter
eggs alright we're not gonna do that
is it me or is the music [ __ ]
annoying Jesus
it's probably me I'm the one being a
knight okay
too much pity pie uncut it's not I got I
swear like okay we're good we're good
we're good ah [ __ ] that was that was
that was not me I swear
never again all right all right all
right [ __ ] duck in the butt ah I said
no matter what didn't I cut my arm
whatever keep running [ __ ] keep running
yeah I got this yeah oh don't eat arms
to win I just need my zombie boss okay
that was weird he did not really seem to
care did he anymore like I guess I'm
supposed to catch aa little dance 15 out
of 15 that's right I hope my mom is
watching right now kiss that [ __ ] bribe
a pretty part of me if I'm assessing
myself hi mom alright that was not to my
mom that was something that was to me
watching this later what you don't get
yourself in the mirror
Lysol nice I like this song better [ __ ]
Jesus Christ oh god oh god oh oh [ __ ] me
that's scared me oh okay ah okay this
game is scarier than a mission that's
that's good to know good stuff good
stuff get really good stuff
keep reading I'm legit sweating and it's
not because it's hide zombie games are
scary man oh Jesus
that was [ __ ] close every couple the
lag man calm down whoa that mix my hair
I don't have hair but if I had hair I
would have missed it gold sweet sweet
baby Jesus is on their side
I imagine he would be on their side with
zombies but maybe that's just me our God
we got to speed up that the thing is
going down the falls
Oh God we're fine we're fine we're gonna
keep doing it I'm a dolphin [ __ ] I'm a
dolphin oh no wait that's a seal dammit
okay we can still do it go in
go dutch what is it he saying the
[ __ ] dodgeball move a duck dodge roll
duck it bothers me that I don't remember
I should not be coding things I don't
know what they wear they say wait here
you can't see it but that really did
scare me that's well scare it on the
inside we're fine so far we're fine keep
going keep going don't stop no matter
what uncut in the but don't stop no
matter what don't stop no matter what
don't stop believin Dada okay don't stop
no matter what don't stop no matter what
don't step no matter what Oh God ah come
on in come on you sexy set up a bit good
good good
Oh get up Oh I'm sweating balls
all right we're throw the head now Wow
nailed it yeah that's
what do I do now okay I get to the
checkpoint gotta go so fast
gotta go so fast [ __ ] gotta go so fast
gotta go away fast
I gotta go real fast [ __ ] gotta go red
pants gotta go right Batman
gotta go rip this gotta go rape admin
[ __ ] I'm getting pumped this is
awesome this game is really fun really
exciting really swag really nice I like
it there we go Oh God
gotta throw rock oh you kidding me oh
that's awkward
okay let's try that again all right all
right all right all right like a great
man once said Oh God
oh [ __ ] what that [ __ ] physics how do
they work not like that I'm pretty sure
okay
it's annoying cuz I got on the first try
I shouldn't have [ __ ] that but I feel
bad I'm sorry I'll show you later
attacking the okay wait sorry
I need a [ __ ] there we go
nice very smack very nice I like it
come on come on [ __ ] that's not keep
rolling keep on rollin rollin rollin
rollin I don't know why I kill the
chickens I don't know why there is
chickens but nailed it [ __ ] [ __ ] you
invisible dog meat Oh God
I'm fine I swear to God him [ __ ] you
he's a [ __ ] game I'm so sorry I love
this game ten out of ten IMDB it's not
the game it's me okay here we go
ducky didn't help at all no this ha ha
ha oh god yeah I don't know why it's so
awkward to throw the head the [ __ ] am I
looking at
that's an awkward Chester is it okay now
here we go
almost there baby I think there I can do
a shortcut here there we go there we go
here this damn nail then now goddamn it
no no keep fighting keep fighting back
oh love it yeah yeah
bah go back [ __ ] okay
yes I lost my oh god oh god my cut my
ass almost got cut that's not a good
thing in the last time I checked killing
it killing it for my breast and my hope
sorry sorry that was offensive
and that really every gap
all right doing good anytime I say I do
good I do bad I don't know why I bother
doing [ __ ] doing so bad oh man I wish I
was doing better I wish I was good at
games cuz holy [ __ ] this is embarrassing
I'm so bad I'm okay I don't even know
how to dance this is really awkward
sorry I got a little too excited there
all right we are going to do another one
didn't we just do that one I think we
just did that one
let's do this one okay so this one
combines a little bit of story in
gameplay like any game must have a great
story and so does this game I don't know
why they bother telling a story maybe
maybe you know it maybe that's a good
the [ __ ] is this
it's not a troll okay oh yes so here I
can dodge right nailed a nail killing it
killing it killing it for my house so
here I got to cut off my legs and then
crawl
let's go balls first hey are my legs
still with me the [ __ ] oh ok now we can
go in here like a little bunny in this
game you can crawl like a bunny ten out
of ten best game with bunny again and we
can go up here now we got a eight and
throw where though oh yeah
BAM man that was a great angle of my ass
I wish if we couldn't replay that but I
guess that's the problem when the uncut
in the butt
ironically okay awkward silence okay
rolling it as a head through other yes
are we almost there
hey [ __ ] of course
I don't see how that's all right I don't
see how that's making it better make it
until you fake it or fake it until you
make it break it until you shake it
everybody loves clowns now that's just
straight-up [ __ ] lying isn't it okay
wait we play as a head still
but I'm sorry but the sound of the head
sounds like stereo fapping oh you don't
know what that is
Goga light alright no one loves clowns
how about that so this is kind of like a
boss battle and I [ __ ] hate clowns
more than I more than I hate a lot of
things more than I hate and your farts
yep
think about that for a minute not too
long though
okay here we go I'm guessing this is the
exit
alright I'll go up I'll follow the lines
crippled Cindy well she's cute
might be something bred to date later
dodge there that thing killing it
killing it not only got mate all right
we're gonna go up here [ __ ] I hate
goddamn it don't try and be a platformer
like this I don't like it but ok we are
we gonna get this yes we are
let's wait for the thing it looks so
cute I want to kiss his bike what you
don't want to do it shut up alright
here's the cannon that's a really large
cannon I'm impressed
all right so I think we're gonna shoot
whoa that's trippy there yeah the show
must oh okay we died but we we gave him
damage oh god oh god this is annoying
[ __ ] oh I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
everyone don't worry about it all right
where's the other Canon third okay oh
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] [ __ ] me is this gonna be
annoying I'm sweating already this is
not good
ed is the one who's supposed to be
sweating actually I don't know if the
zombies sweat technically yes I would
bet yeah [ __ ] my ass
it's faster now
that's leaky setup a [ __ ] all right all
right all right all right all right
but that that Beth Beth Beth Beth Beth
Beth Beth Beth Beth
yeah get in [ __ ] okay all right boom
[ __ ]
did we get it we got it Wow that's what
I'm talking about
latest that's for my ladies out there
there's no one watching I know
okay here we go
one more okay this is gonna be a problem
I can tell this is gonna be annoying as
[ __ ]
candy sausage taste the sweet meat yeah
how did that sounds awesome so where the
[ __ ] with the last Ken oh it's up there
uh oh [ __ ] me is coming from behind but
uh that sounded sexual shut up ah stop
okay we're fine ah
we're [ __ ] bi I'm sweating dodge duck
whoa Jesus Christ I feel like I'm like a
boss okay
no don't fly out alright he's doing the
DJ's [ __ ] now he [ __ ] David Greta
that [ __ ] miss me [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] where is Singh why our
resin sorry
alright I'm fine no god damn it that's
annoying
I'm sweating balls cuz this has been
going fine so far and I don't want it to
[ __ ] up now
god I hate clowns hey let's make the
most annoying [ __ ] left
I rest my case I rest my [ __ ] case
Your Honor what is even going on
how could I could I pass they are crying
how could I possibly do it stop
I'm cut in the butt come on David Greta
[ __ ] it beats up my ass [ __ ]
that's right spin do that do that too
[ __ ] deviation okay
starting to eat DJ's more than clowns I
don't even
am I going I'm going in the wrong
[ __ ] the [ __ ] where am I supposed
to go okay wait let me let me have a
look all right I'll go up okay I see it
now
I was going the wrong way we're fine
we're [ __ ] fine look at this I'm just
gonna time it look
contain contain and don't release just
like ran my desk with their parts oh
please please this has been going so
well so far please I think I beg you
[ __ ] is that fair
why am i playing
okay
I got this
ah all right well now we go to the
[ __ ] part when I'm just legit [ __ ]
pissed
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] ever [ __ ]
started taste us [ __ ] christ
[ __ ] uncut in the buddies and jump it's
[ __ ] a Tara [ __ ] eyes
the game was stuck get up get [ __ ]
stop - Zack stop dancing
Oh
it's ridiculous
I can't even say offensive stuff
[ __ ] Department okay
what the [ __ ] is this part
my god
this is
this is [ __ ] worse than blood-borne
okay let
get up get up get up get up get up thank
you
or you carry bag
udemy grad on my ass I'm gonna [ __ ] you
jump job job
okay where's the [ __ ] cannon there it
is oh I was just supposed to go to the
different direction okay okay it's my
phone calling oh it's my dear all that
I'm doing uncut in the butt okay
oh god have mercy on my soul for Edgar
please I'm gonna cry diarrhea if I die
now seriously please please please
please
okay you can suck my big fat zombie dick
oh whoa whoa that [ __ ] got intense said
that oh I don't even give a [ __ ]
hi I don't know what to say I
I I want to thank my mom and all right
so that was I'm cut in the butt
uncut in the butt did you enjoy it let
me know leave a comment and alike
especially and if they if I if it gets a
lot of support that means you liked it
so I I do pay attention to these things
I think it was fun until the point where
I lost my [ __ ] but other than that
that's it for me for now thank you for
watching this video
oh my god I would just redo the outro
but I [ __ ] can bend an edge really
cool game it's in the description check
it out if you enjoy it I'm gonna I
already kissed it so I professed